c'est rory merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on l'a entendu
en matière de lutte contre l'immigration
illégale le gouvernement britannique se
veut très ferme comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer c'est l'effet breakes site
oui on sait l'effet pour exciter puis
c'est une tendance c'est naturel chez
nos amis britanniques de s'isoler et
puis ça fait près de 20 ans que cette
question migratoire est à l'agenda
politique
la grande bretagne a fait pression sur
la france pour que cette dernière en
réalité face la police
boyer dans un certain nombre de subsides
jour apple qui lie à un traité entre la
grande bretagne et la france qui
s'appelle le traité du touquet qui a été
revisité en janvier 2018 et qui
transfère de fait à la france
la charge de contrôler les frontières du
côté de calais et d'empêcher un certain
nombre de passages donc vers la
grande-bretagne donc c'est une position
assez classique du gouvernement
conservateur qui avait promis d'ailleurs
vos électeurs à l'opinion publique en
grande bretagne qu'avec le break site
il n'y aurait plus d'immigration est
évidemment c'était un gros mensonge
il y a toujours de l'immigration en
grande-bretagne
non aujourd'hui le discours oui oui la
secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur on l'a
entendu elle souhaite organiser une
refonte complète du système de demande
d'asile elle le juge fondamentalement
défaillant est-ce que sur ce constat
vous la rejoignent et est ce que le
système est vraiment défaillants comme
le souligne prix pitt ribatel il ya de
gros problèmes en grande bretagne autour
de ce système
d'abord il y a une durée d'examen qui
est extrêmement longue
plus d'un an mais le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile en grande bretagne
n'a rien à voir avec le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile qui était cueilli par
les principaux pays sur le continent
le nombre de demandeurs d'asile sont
environ 40000 en grande bretagne et
17000 accepté
pour mémoire pour l'allemagne où pour la
france de sable aux alentours de 140
mille annuellement
donc il ya eu manifestement un discours
à destination de l'opinion publique
en fait ce que dit le secrétaire la
secrétaire d'état
c'est qu'elle veut remettre en cause la
capacité des demandeurs d'asile à faire
appel des décisions en première instance
qui sont prises et qui sut leur sont
défavorables dans le système c'est quand
même assez particulier de la part d'un
pays qui est le chantre de la démocratie
que de refuser ou de préparer en tout
cas un dispositif qui empêche d'avoir
recours devant la justice quand une
décision est négative mais vous savez la
grande bretagne est une île ça n'aura
pas changé
demain et donc la tentation de
l'externalisation a toujours existé
depuis tony blair a
aujourd'hui il n'y a rien de
véritablement changé alors oui tiens
risque selon la presse
il est de même plusieurs propositions
comme envoyer les demandeurs d'asile sur
un des territoires au milieu de
l'atlantique transformé de vieux ferry
en centre pour migrants ou encore
générer des vagues dans la manche est ce
que c'est de la provocation volontaire
selon vous pourquoi comment vous vous
comprenez ça oui mais c'est évidemment
de la provocation c'est voilà alors de
la provocation faut faire attention
parce que de cette provocation peut
surgir des monstres on a vu des systèmes
qui sont mis en place par exemple en
australie ou littéralement les
demandeurs d'asile étaient placés sur
des îles à l'isolément et c'est enfin la
grande bretagne n'est pas le str ali
elle a un rôle à jouer et à continuer à
jouer
d'ailleurs en europe et dans le monde
et je rappelle que les demandeurs
d'asile qui arrive en grande bretagne
sont pour la plupart des personnes qui
viennent des anciennes colonies de la
grande bretagne et qu'il me semble que
la grande bretagne doit prendre sa part
de l'accueil elle doit le faire dans un
système équilibré et les propositions
qui sont celles qui sont formulées
aujourd'hui ne le sont pas alors on
verra ce qui va sortir de ddd du
secrétariat d'état mais je voudrais
quand même vous préciser qu'aujourd'hui
la grande bretagne des systèmes de
rétention les plus dures en europe
lorsque les demandeurs d'asile sont mis
parce qu'ils sont en situation
irrégulière en rétention
ça peut durer des années la rétention
est illimité et aujourd'hui le système
d'accueil est totalement sinistré
et comme les procédures durent très
longtemps
en réalité les demandeurs d'asile qui
sont dans cette procédure sont environ 5
euros 60 pour survivre autrement dit la
destination grande bretagne est une
destination qui est qu'ils continuent à
être survendu par les passeurs mais qui
n'a rien à voir avec la réalité de la
grande bretagne et je pense que il faut
absolument trouver les voies d'une
équipe d'un équilibre notamment entre
l'union européenne et la grande bretagne
ça fera forcément partie du deal qui
sera proposé et qui continue d'en
négocier dans le cadre du du break site
merci en tout cas thierry henry d'avoir
répondu à deux questions rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'association
france fraternité